wow
[Musica]
[Applauso]
no no
[Musica]
[Applauso]
entusiasmo a questa parola così piena di
significato eppure non lo so così poco
sentita
pure a che fare con l'energia con il
coinvolgimento con il voler fare le cose
come state
una biblioteca
ragazzi è facile basta dire bene che non
abbiamo mica tempo per i problemi di
unione di noi qua quindi siamo alter ex
asiago come estate
ora tutti falsi che tanto che
l'entusiasmo un po ci dimentichiamo dei
problemi l'entusiasmo è la base di tutto
considerate l'interazione tra due
persone si possono dire le cose o si può
coinvolgere emozionare
ma come ci si emoziona
beh
è viva
c'è una bella parola si chiama emotion
hochhuth
transfert emozionale bella si chiama
anche contagio emozionale ma non è
periodo per chiamarla così
ecco la situazione in cui in
un'interazione tra due persone quello
che io sento o trasferisco a chi mi
ascolta e lo sente non è magia nera
funziona sul serio posto che tu per
primo si senta coinvolto emozionalmente
altrimenti cosa trasferisci devi to
sentire le emozioni devi volerla
trasferire che poi devi volere anche
creare una connessione un legame con chi
sta dall'altra parte
ci devi tenere in qualche modo questa
cosa l'avete provata
tutti e anche fisica ha a che fare con i
neuroni specchio
vi ricordate quando gonfiate un
palloncino anti agli amici
e loro gonfiavano le guance solo nel
vedervi
è il vostro coinvolgimento l'emozione
era talmente forte
fra il tentare di non farvi esplodere il
cervello
che veniva sentito anche da loro
nel mio percorso ho sempre tentato di
capire come far trasferire a far
percepire agli altri quello che sento
soprattutto su temi che mi stanno a
cuore a un canale youtube dove utilizzo
serietà assieme a un po di sana celenza
parlo di di avventure di pensieri di
viaggi mentali però sotto c'era sempre
questo questa parola
percezione
ma è cos'è la percezione
ma è la versione soggettiva della realtà
il punto è che oggi è difficile
agganciare le persone siamo
disinteressati voi starete già pensando
alla pausa
ecco perché bisogna pensare a una cosa
basilare dell'essere umano voi tu sei
qui perché sei protagonista della tua
vita tu sei l'eroe della tua storia
questo è il tuo momento
questa è quella parte del tuo libro
sei qui perché vuoi farti ispirare
perché voi fatta sarà una giornata
diversa perché vuoi farti intrattenere e
noi qui personaggi secondari tutti palco
speaker pubblico musica
siamo qui per te
è un po quella sensazione che abbiamo
sempre avuto alla truman show no
surreale
surreale percezione la cosa è reale
cos'è reale
si potrebbe dire che ogni essere vivente
sulla faccia della terra vive la propria
realtà ma è più corretto dire che ogni
essere vivente sulla faccia della terra
vive la propria allucinazione e quando
ci troviamo d'accordo la chiamiamo
realtà questa è una famosa frase di dal
neuroscienziato anni il set ma è come è
possibile non abbiamo accesso alla
realtà punto questa cosa la possiamo
vedere in così tanti ambiti diversi
dalle neuroscienze
all'arte alla fisica quantistica la
chimica lo storytelling alla linguistica
con il vostro partner
ma cosa ho fatto ci devi arrivare da
solo
ovvero esci dalla tua realtà ed entra
nei meandri della mia
viviamo una versione editata e personale
della realtà agli input arrivano sì però
poi vengono letti dall esperienza di
vita vissuta
violetto arteprima sono un artista e
sono follemente innamorato
quindi e questo è il mio la mia opera ok
amore però se tu arrivi il tempo dopo
con la tua giornata con i tuoi casini
eccetera
magari cv di sangue
qual è la realtà il rosso è significato
relativo
viviamo una vita di stenti e significati
però se c'è una una voragine a trame la
realtà
allora beh c'è una voragine ancora più
grande tra me è una persona è un'altra
persona
abbiamo un punto di vista differente
quindi come faccio arrivare a te
devo capire dove sei nella mappa
condividi posizione e via fosse così
facile però nella comunicazione
importante perché io devo pensare anche
che se ti dico di svoltare a sinistra
per me la destra
quindi dopo un attimo togliermi da
questa visione egocentrica di me stesso
per dedicarmi a te
ecco perché la percezione è così
importante nella comunicazione
perché siamo tutti un po registi
della storia di qualcun altro
perché vi dico tutto questo va in parte
perché sono estremamente logorroico ma
anche perché è il the best di asiago a
questo tema countdown
probabilmente ne avrete già sentito
parlare sembra che abbiamo un problemino
con il pianeta questa irrefrenabile
voglia di renderlo uniformemente
caraibico gomiti da tutte le parti in
fra dt anche al polo nord ma non
funziona
quindi perché continuiamo imperterriti
a una definizione dell'essere umano
molto carina
essere umano colui che tagli agli alberi
ne produce carta e ci scrive sopra
salviamo gli alberi
non siamo coerenti ma siamo bravi con le
cose cicliche il punto è che il problema
è serio restiamo però sottovalutando un
tema importante che è quello della
comunicazione
noi persone comuni qua che cosa
c'entriamo con il cambiamento climatico
se pensiamo di centrarci ma son
consciamente ci sentiamo anche molto
personaggi secondari
siamo rassegnati
siamo in negazione ci sentiamo impotenti
e quindi ci escludiamo dalla storia ma
ci proviamo sensibilizzarci l'orso
polare al polo senza casa
né empatia
a livello emozionale lo sentiamo tutto
ne siamo sicuri si no
e forte beh non per il nostro cervello
c'è una parte qua davanti che si chiama
corteccia prefrontale mediale e a che
fare con l'attività mentale e con il se
referenziale in sostanza la sensazione
del sé e i comportamenti ed emozioni
annesse
attiva molto quando pensiamo noi stessi
chiaramente autoreferenziale ma è meno
attiva quando iniziamo a pensare agli
amici ai parenti e zero attiva quando
pensiamo agli sconosciuti
ci sta ma con la risonanza magnetica si
è scoperto che non si accende nemmeno
quando pensiamo al nostro se del futuro
in sostanza non riconosciamo il nostro
sia del futuro come parte di noi
immaginatevi l'orso è capito come questa
cosa crei non pochi casini con un
problema che ha a che fare non solo col
oggi ma con gli obiettivi del 2030 del
allora usiamo altri sistemi il senso di
colpa ma ancora non funzionano perché ci
togliamo con il pensiero pensiamo ad
altro si chiama dissonanza cognitiva in
sostanza il cervello fa troppa fatica a
contrastare le credenze le connessioni
neurali che abbiamo sviluppato per anni
per cui sposta l'attenzione esposta alle
energie e ci fa pensare ad altro
in sostanza non c'è niente di peggio del
problema del cambiamento climatico per
il tipo di mentalità che abbiamo oggi
è lento non sa che fare con il presente
non ha a che fare con noi personalmente
nella nostra quotidianità di conseguenza
è perfetto come match dalla nostra
psicologia
la nostra realtà in soggettiva ricordate
ok ma quindi cioè
infradito
potrei parlarvi di svariati strumenti ma
come detto siete voi gli eroi qui quindi
preferisco contagiarvi con un solo
messaggio
quando parlate di cambiamento climatico
ma anche in generale quando parlate con
qualcuno quando discutete quando volete
farvi capire
pensate all'eroe della storia la persona
che avete davanti
partita da loro è la regola di sempre e
proprio per questo non viene mai presa
in considerazione
pensate mettetevi nei suoi panni
percepite i suoi pensieri capite dove
vuole andare
ma
fatelo con entusiasmo
fatelo con coinvolgimento con emozione
contagio emozionale siamo controllati
dalle emozioni facciamo cose assurde per
via delle emozioni
è un cocktail chimico che funziona per
chiunque e per di più è gratis
questo è il modo per creare visione
comune che è un modo chiave di risolvere
i problemi
mi sembra impossibile
se si provate a cambiare la vostra
versione soggettiva delle realtà in modo
da colmare un po quello strano divario
che abbiamo tra esseri umani
perché a mio avviso
non c'è altra soluzione che essere
ottimisti
grazie
[Applauso]